you don't have to pretend that Iran was
a sensible moderate Democratic regime to
admit the truth
which is that the Obama Iran deal has
actually worked out pretty well for
years at this point and I was a critic
of some aspects of that deal when it was
first signed but I was overall a
supporter of the deal and in fact when I
was on Fox News last week the right-wing
guests as well as the host who kind of
teamed up on me we're arguing that
Donald Trump deserves credit for nine
months without a North Korean missile
test and if that's true then when it
comes to the Iran deal clearly President
Obama deserved and arguably still
deserves credit for year after year
after year over Iran not testing nukes
and not doing nuclear advancement and
not violating the terms of that deal and
what we now have is Iran threatening war
against the United States and
threatening Donald Trump specifically
with what they're calling the mother of
all wars after Donald Trump has become
increasingly hostile to Iran and on his
position with regard to the Iranian
regime including the recent announcement
which we covered extensively about
Donald Trump planning to pull out of the
Iran nuclear deal even though as far as
we know as far as inspectors know as far
as the checks and balances that exist as
part of that deal Iran hasn't violated
the terms of the deal so there's a few
different layers of analysis here number
one big picture remember that it was
Hillary Clinton who we were told was
going to get us into Wars but here is
yet another country with which Donald
Trump is inching closer to a war so
let's get to what the Iranian president
said and of course Donald Trump has
responded as he often does on Twitter
Iran's president Hassan rouhani saying
yesterday quote don't play with fire or
you will regret Iranian people are the
master and they will never bow to anyone
America should no peace with Iran is the
mother of all peace but he later
threatened in the statement that war
with Iran is the mother of all wars and
of course Donald Trump predictably and
this may even have been a calculated
decision by Iran knowing that Donald
Trump is unable to resist acting like a
normal person because he's not one and
Trump immediately responding exactly as
we would expect on Twitter with more
threats saying to Iranian president
rouhani never is all in caps by the way
if you're if you're not looking at this
never ever threaten the United States
again or you will suffer consequences
the likes of which few throughout
history have ever suffered before we are
no longer a country I guess that's a
reference to Obama that will stand for
your demented words of violence and
death be cautious this is an issue where
the right is probably going to
successfully turn it around and say
things like look this is proof that Iran
is unhinged and belligerent and so we
should get out of the Iran deal and
Trump is right to be tough with them and
of course they'll accuse the left and me
of being soft and wanting to cower in
fear as Iran threatens war no you're
deliberately misunderstanding this if
that's what you think I am saying I have
been abundantly clear that Iran is a
belligerent unhinged theocracy with an
increasingly secular young population
that doesn't want conflict with the
United States right that that's what's
going on in Iran we had a good thing
going we had a deal not a perfect deal
but a pretty good deal and as long as
the United States kept up its end
meaning you stay in the deal if Iran
doesn't violate it then we have leverage
over them if they go rogue in other
words if we do our part and stay in the
deal and Iran goes rogue violates that
deal now we actually have political
capital to spend when it comes to a
response but now in comes Trump wants to
undo anything with Barack Obama's name
on it including the Iran deal and that
is going now out of the way to provoke
Iran in addition to threatening quote
the strongest sanctions in history when
Iran hasn't violated the deal so I'm
here saying if Iran does something in
violation of the deal then the u.s. is
actually in a better position to
retaliate we could debate at that time
what is the retaliation that
Trump wants and does that make sense but
at least we can say Iran violated the
deal now there can be repercussions but
when a ron has cooperated to the extent
that we can check and the u.s. simply
says now we're out obama was wrong to do
the deal we're gonna put on the
strongest sanctions in history that is
irrational hostility towards Iran and
I'm not saying Iran doesn't deserve
sanctions I'm not saying Iran is a
geopolitical partner to be trusted they
are not a geopolitical partner to be
trusted but if you have something that
appears to be keeping them less
escalated and agitated and the Iran deal
seemed to be doing that build on it
rather than destroy it and Iran is an
extremist nation like many others we
have to deal with if you've gotten more
control if you've gotten them more under
control than others then maybe focus
elsewhere right focus on Russian active
measures instead of rewarding Russia for
their bad behavior or focus on Saudi
Arabia's extremist regime instead of
selling them weapons or work on getting
some concessions from Israel instead of
moving the embassy to Jerusalem right
don't go out of your way to anger Iran
for no reason whatsoever as far as the
people who are skipping the geopolitics
because there are people who are
ignoring the fact that we are causing
Iran to escalate by virtue of the
haphazard pulling out of the Iran deal
or announcement of the pulling out of
the Iran deal threats of the strongest
sanctions ever skipping the geopolitics
there are some people who are going to
bring it on and we can destroy Iran in a
war Iran has nothing honest militarily
yeah our military is much bigger than
Iran's but Iran is in Iraq Iran has a
massive military compared to Iraq and
war with Iran would be a completely
different thing than Iraq I'm not saying
the United States would quote lose but
you have to remember that in quote
winning against Iraq if you believe that
we did we suffered 4,000 or more
American servicemember casualties likely
a hundred thousand or more Iraqi
civilians died and the idea that there's
going to be anything even remotely
similar if we were to go with Iran
absolute and total joke but I actually
don't think that's the right
conversation now the correct
conversation is why is Trump ruining
something that was at least going okay
and going better than it had been for
years and the fear the threat now
becomes is Trump more unhinged by these
threats then Iran is by our backing out
of the nuclear deal and does Trump start
to proactively plan for or push for or
drive to war with Iran and if he is
who's going to stop him we know he
wanted to go to war with Venezuela and
he was talked out of it we know that he
was starting to get belligerent about
military action against North Korea
unfortunately that hasn't happened I
don't know if we can count on chief of
staff John Kelly because he's
increasingly at odds with Trump Stephen
Miller is not going to talk Trump out of
a war with Iran is john bolton
going to talk trump out of a war with
iran this is why we have to be
extraordinarily concerned and remember
supposedly it was Hillary who was going
to get us into multiple Wars it's Trump
who's been pushing for multiple Wars
behind the scenes